c'est touchant quoi c'est touchant parce
que ça fait un moment que je retravaille
ça va coûter beaucoup ceux de quoi
demain est fait pour vous bon ben c'est
fini c'est fini je finis parce que là
vous allez fermer à jamais fermé c'était
mon activité principale
ça fait un moment
là c'est fini pour moi trifi parce que
les sommes qu'ils ont coupé la cedeao
que j'ai planqué faisable à des puits en
depuis en 2009 sa procédure qu'il a déjà
ça fait 2009 en 2018 quand même les
antilles pendant un moment ça vous
n'avez toujours pas de réponse
concernant un accompagnement et puis un
financier ou hausse puisque c'était ça
aussi votre problème
non non j'ai pas jusqu'ici en plus ils
ont ils ont employé un entreprise puis
il paraît que c'est moi qui doit payer
l'entreprise pour la destruction
beaucoup